this report was born of a crime that
shocked and sickened in equal measure in
March 2021 Sarah everard was abducted
tortured raped and killed by a serving
officer in the metropolitan police Wayne
cousins was jailed for life that case
prompted another woman to come forward
accusing another officer David Carrick
was convicted of more than 20 rapes of
12 victims spanning 17 years the Met's
failure in its duty to vet officers and
protect women and children Central to
Louise Casey's findings rather than see
one person or a bad apple or a Roman
what you should do in a situation like
this is look at whether your entire
system is copper bottomed to root out
the Predators and not allow them in in
the first place in her report she also
finds that police protection for
children and women is failing saying an
overworked inexperienced Workforce
police's Child Protection rape and
serious sexual offenses officers have to
contend with overstuffed dilapidated or
broken fridges and freezers containing
evidence including the rape kicks of
Victor Sims she points to bullying
racism and sexism within the specialist
Firearms unit and calls the
Parliamentary and diplomatic protection
unit where cousins and Carrick both
worked a dark corner of the force but
the whole Force she said was
institutionally homophobic misogynistic
and racist taken as a whole this report
is entirely condemning of this
organization it says the Metropolitan
Police has lost public support and
consent needs to wake up and engage in
comprehensive wholesale reform I accept
Her diagnosis about the racism misogyny
homophobia in the organization and also
that we have these systemic failings
management failings and cultural
failings
I understand her use of the term
institutional it's not a term I use
myself I'm a practical police officer I
have to use language that's unambiguous
and is apolitical campaigners though are
already worried that reforms won't go
far enough the sad truth of the matter
is that report after reporting to the
Met police both in terms of individuals
and their misconduct as well as the
institutions sit on shelves and collect
dust Louise Casey says her
recommendations from Specialists sexual
assault units to new systems for dealing
with misconduct to bringing in external
expertise aren't to be picked from but
to be implemented as a whole otherwise
she says the force may need to be broken
up Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera London